I wanted to watch this with you there's
a new
um it's a live event that's coming up
yeah and you might be thinking is it the
you know the live stream of Coachella
weekend two no not really okay it's
something similar oh
uh this is called The Art of Living and
this is a Matthew Mcconaughey live
stream we are doing The Art of Living
experience to help you write your new
story and I'm damn excited to take this
journey with you you know he sounds like
Biden yeah he does yeah we can take this
ride together on the highway so you can
take this ride together
on a highway
to corn to the cornfield corn pot
cornfield
what is this Matthew